new video shows the border is anything
but under control
fox news cameras capturing exclusive
footage again of dozens of migrants
crossing the rio grande river
in broad daylight and a texas farmer and
his family found
five young migrants including a baby
abandoned in the blistering heat
here's the moment they were found
no mother no mother no father
no nothing this is one of our
workers wives right here taking care of
this tiny one
no one with these children
so juan you got 20 governors urging
biden to
to act on this crisis there's a harvard
poll that says that they uh
the respondents overwhelmingly want
action now
even to embrace uh trump's former border
goals because
they seem to be working can you actually
say to these people hey
this has happened before this has been
around forever do you think they're
going to buy that
stick i don't think it's a stick and i
don't think anybody has to buy it i just
think they have to look for themselves
i mean you can show these videos you did
one yesterday then one today
you know it's one video out of context
about you know as i said yesterday
people have been crossing the rio grande
for centuries
uh in terms of illegal immigration but
the broader point about whether the
border is open or the border is
closed i think that you know again i
just asked people to look at the facts
because the facts
are that the coyotes may have told
people oh
with president biden they're going to
let you in but the fact is over the last
month we've seen an 88 nearly 90 percent
drop in the number of unaccompanied
minors crossing that border
and we've seen on also a similar high
level of drop in terms of the number of
arrests
of illegal immigrants of any age
crossing the border
indicating that there are fewer people
trying to cross so
to my mind we have to just stop all the
alarmist
type of you know attitude and like
making this video into something that's
never happened before
and say we need we need action and i
think that's what you're hearing from
the governors
we need action to deal with our broken
immigration system
and the really the president for you
know all you talk about
oh build a wall of this that wouldn't
have stopped people crossing the rio
grande
what we need is congress what we need is
congress
to organize a legal immigration system
a better border security system make a
deal republicans and democrats
let's come together and stop the selfies
and the
you know you keep saying stop the
selfies yeah but it was the democrats
the democrats who pioneered the selfies
you remember aoc you keep saying stop
the selfies you need new talking points
number one i'm glad that you agree that
videos out of context are wrong
finally and number two the number of
migrant children have
doubled you've actually you've the
number of migrant children have doubled
in the last two
months uh jesse are there any other
facts you want
children has decreased no it's double
gone downgraded
let me let me address something are you
accusing our producers
to be misinformed here the situation on
the border is not improving
border crossings are not down we've had
two
straight months of over 170 thousand
border crossers
that is her two straight months of 20
year highs
in fact month over month adults
are found crossing more than they were
before
also juan says this is normal it is not
normal for a
parade of 50 people from venezuela
pouring across the rio grande river in
broad daylight
and then just turning themselves over
over to our border patrol agents to game
the
asylum system the second thing they like
to say
is oh well they're really speeding up
the process of getting these kids out of
custody
that was debunked today by the
associated press
who says the binding administration has
more than doubled the amount of children
in custody over the last two months they
are now keeping
21 000 unaccompanied meyers in federal
custody
in a secret network of 20 to 200
different facilities
across a span of over two dozen states
there's one fort in texas that has over
four
thousand unaccompanied minors packed
tight into it
and the last thing you always hear about
republicans taking selfies
and congress needs to act republicans
were taking pictures of kids in cages
because biden wouldn't let the press
into the facility and the last time i
checked republicans don't control
either chamber nancy and chuck have not
moved on any immigration
policy change and that is on them
and not just to point out from our from
our research packet and i trust our
producers on this
i would never doubt the data that they
give us this is confidential data dana
obtained by the ap
which shows the number i mean you can
laugh i guess he's laughing about the
migrant children
in government custody more than doubled
in the past two months
uh so that's just that's i mean you can
laugh at this i guess it's funny to you
but anyway it's i i think dana said over
the last month
if you don't distort the numbers i won't
have no i'm i'm reading it i'm actually
reading it went up
you had your chance you had your chance
you know you had your chance all right
dana yeah you added your name
and you've written you distort that i
know i'm reading it from oh
god help us um i said it's down
80 plus percent over the last month it's
up
two months if you can't read the stats
you're confused one
yeah yeah you're confused yeah i think
oh yeah right dana
i'm trying to get you i'm having a hard
time uh
you could argue that those that farmer
saved those kids lives
and if that farmer wasn't there we would
have a very we'd be having a very
different discussion right now
well right what and what about that
farmers like what if what if it had
gotten to the point where the little
baby who was so dehydrated they said she
was barely moving
what if she was what if she hadn't
survived yeah and then
the farmer and his wife happen upon this
tragedy and then they have that on their
conscience that's not fair
to them at all and it's terrible for
these girls
this this is the inhumanity of all of
this and
i have another question we when you show
that video
that it's actually news footage and look
other networks
right they're free to go and do coverage
too they were just
our cameras were just there they just
happened to be there like okay
we're just showing you what we're seeing
here and you can
you can decide with your own eyes like
what what you're saying but there's a
video
there's a the guy in there jesse pointed
him out yesterday he's the coyote with
the um
mask around his face yeah and we saw him
yesterday
and we saw him today yeah and he's
bringing the venezuelans across and he
gets paid
once they get across he doesn't care
what happens to them after that i want
to know this
why is that that why isn't that guy
getting arrested right
why are we taking him out good question
i i don't understand that no we
we got eyes on him he's right there yeah
he's on fox more often than my pillow
guy
katie um to to dana's point
it's amazing how tragedy is covered when
the media's chosen leader is in power
they've suddenly become journalism
suddenly becomes like an act of
smothering
they put out the story or they just
don't even look at it
well yeah and to dana's point i have a
friend who has a ranch down on the
border in texas and spends a lot of time
working on other ranches and yesterday
he texted me and he said
ranchers are starting to find bodies
more often but they won't ever show that
they said it's getting hot and they
aren't prepared to deal with the
situation
so it is not normal for people to be
dying on private property and ranches
in texas it's not normal to drop off
little babies that can't even
walk yet on ranches and abandon them
that is not normal
and it's certainly not humane as the
biden administration has repeatedly
argued they've said
over and over again our policies are
more humane than the trump
administration's policies well guess
what this is
the opposite of humane open borders are
inhumane borders
we know this and to say that it's being
blown out of proportion or that it just
happens all the time
is opposite of what this administration
told us they were going to do
and it's not right it's wrong yeah and
we have to remind ourselves that the
wall
is a literal representation of a
disincentive
and you remove that wall that is a
message hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else